[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to chess openings
explained of course this is the class
where i look at chess openings
and then explain them uh today i am
continuing the series on the night earth
and we are going to look
at what uh sort of has the reputation as
being the most difficult the most theory
heavy line
and hopefully by the end of the class we
will see
that while there are a lot of moves uh
they are kind of linear so it doesn't
take as much
study as much uh theory heavy learning
as you might expect of course i'm
talking about the bishop
g5 line in the najdorf for a long time
and this has been
the most respected try against the night
or if this is
sort of what the top players are saying
yeah this is it if we're gonna beat the
night or if we can
rely on bishop g5 to create some
complications
so i wanted to start off with a game
between sergey karjakin and maxime
vashilograv
and this is nowadays i think the
main line for these top level players of
course mvl
is perhaps the best night or player of
all time and
he has very much pioneered this line
against bishop g5 so let's take a look
at it
the game starts with e4 c5
knight f3 d6 d4
takes takes knight f6 knight c3
a6 entering of course the najdorf then
we have
this move bishop g5 so this is the move
i'm talking about
this denotes the bishop g5 line uh of
course
you know with the move bishop g5 that
makes sense and this is what people have
historically really struggled with in
the nightdorf now
rather than the typical najdorf e5 it
actually makes a bit more sense
to play the move e6 here and part of the
reason for that
is this bishop is very well placed to
target the knight on f6 to pin it back
to the queen
and so if you make a move like e5
already the d5 square is going to be
very very weak
and that is going to cause black some
pretty significant issues right away
so e6 is a bit better to keep control of
the d5 square
then the line that we are specifically
focusing on today is the next move 7f4
there are other options for white for
example queen f3
queen d2 queen d3 bishop e2 queen e2
various other developing moves like this
are available and we will look at those
eventually
but the real stuff all comes after the
move f4
and now there are a variety of ways that
black can play
in response to this just to name a few
queen b6
for a long time was the most popular
this is the
typical poisoned pawn variation but it's
actually not what i'm going to recommend
here today
we also have the move bishop e7 by black
we have the move knight bd7 queen c7
and also not bishop e7 but queen c7
also this move h6 and what h6
is is uh an attempt to improve upon the
typical poisoned pawn variation with
queen b6 and this is sort of the
variation
that maxine vashir lagrav has pioneered
and it's what he played here
against sergey karjakin after this the
move bishop h4
should be played bishop takes f6 is
very technically a legal move but after
queen takes f6
black sort of has no problems and i'll
get into that in a little bit more depth
a little bit later in the lecture
but for now we'll focus on bishop h4 and
now
queen b6 is the idea and it gets the
name
the poison pawn variation because black
is targeting
this b2 pawn and in fact looking to
capture this pawn
in the meantime white is going to try
and use
this time that black spends to capture
on b2 to prove that this pawn
was a little bit poisoned that this
queen is out of place
because it's snacked on the poisoned
pawn on b2
and white's going to try to make
something out of that extra time that he
has
in the opening with that in mind
there are really two main moves here and
then a few other sidelines that we will
also get to
as well uh the move a3 is an attempt to
keep the b2 pawn
after a3 black really shouldn't be
capturing this guy and then the move
queen d2
is sort of the the variation where black
does go in
and capture on b2 these days
i think a3 is sort of what's seen as
white's best chance at creating some
play
in the poison pawn the lines after queen
d2 have sort of been analyzed almost to
death
and most of them in fact all of them if
black plays correctly i believe
do end up being at least equality for
black
so why can't you take this pawn after a3
well if you do end up capturing of
course knight a4
is the typical trap the pawn on a3
guards the last square
on b4 and indirectly the square on a3 by
allowing the rook to look at it
so this pawn is now uncapturable and
that's what sergey karyakin chose in
this game
by the way from the 2017 london chess
classic
a3 to guard the b4 square defending the
b2 pawn
now we have the move bishop e7 by black
and this is sort of the reason why
we displaced this bishop and put it back
on h4
now after the move bishop e7 we are
actually
sort of creating threats of capturing on
the e4 pawn we have
dislocated this bishop from the g5
square where it's defended to h4 where
it would actually be hanging with check
in many lines
and this is the reason why mvl decides
to include this move h6 it's to put this
bishop
on h4 rather than g5
and we'll see that come into play in a
lot of other variations as well
but for now because this bishop is
undefended it would wants to reroute
itself back to f2
notably challenging the queen on b6 and
now
with its dreams of taking on b2 sort of
vanquished the queen
has to retreat back to c7 and what was
the point of this whole maneuver well
with a3
and with bishop h4 to f2 white has
wasted a little bit of time
and black has alleviated a lot of the
pressure on this diagonal
and gotten his pieces developed pretty
adequately
from here there's really only one setup
that really makes sense
for white in this position it doesn't
make so much sense
to go for king side castling in these
kinds of structures
black is just too well set up for it
with the versatile pawn center
and plans of b5 coming very very quickly
so
white should play queen f3 and look to
queen side castle
and this is what i mean when i say that
the theory uh
is pretty long but it's pretty linear
right white only really has this one
serious plan at least in this a3
variation uh of castling queenside and
then going for an attack on the king's
side so we can go pretty far
with our analysis but we don't have to
go too wide
so to speak now black is happy to
develop with knight b
to d7 just getting all the pieces into
the game and white's going to go ahead
and queenside castle
now rather than castle king's side this
is one of those variations where it
makes a bit more sense for black to keep
the king
in the center the king is just going to
be a little bit more safe there a little
bit more solid
and we'll see that white's plan very
quickly involves pushing all of these
guys forward
and trying to open up the king's side
definitely
don't want our king over there for that
it also has the nice bonus of not
spending time on castles so we can spend
all of our tempi
by pushing on the queen's side and
making immediate counter play
up next we see white pick the move g4
once again this is sort of really the
only serious move by white here
you can try something else like bishop
d3 or king b1 but you're going to play
g4 eventually and it should more or less
transpose and after g4 i'd like you guys
in the chat room
to stop and think and see if you can
come up with
what black's idea should be in
this particular position uh just come up
with some ideas
in general we're not yet really out of
the theory you can go a bit deeper
because like i said the play is sort of
so linear just following
one direct variation but i'd like to
stop here just to talk about some of the
ideas that black is going to have
so what do you guys think
so there's a lot of good ideas
so in the long term definitely playing
something like b4
is going to be on black's mind but we'll
see that this is actually
not the best way of playing in this
particular position at least
immediately it makes a lot more sense
whenever you see this pawn step to f4 to
very seriously consider targeting
the pawn on e4 so in this case the line
i'm going to recommend
is the main move here which is bishop b7
and we'll see that black's play very
often revolves around
making this pawn look like a pretty
serious weakness and because of that
and because of black's second idea which
you guys in the chat have also found
white now has to make a very serious
decision
so if bishop g2 this is an attempt to
over defend the uh e pawn
it makes moves like knight c5 slightly
less effective because queen e2 is now
comfortably defending everything
then black has this second idea in the
position so as you guys in the chat
we're mentioning
we would love to have the e5 square for
our knights
and after bishop g2 we can achieve just
that by playing this move
g5 and this is definitely the way to go
now white uh has to make a decision here
of how he's going to deal with this
threat to the f pawn
most often and in this particular game
we do see the move
h4 come on the board and from here black
can take on f4
and jump this knight into uh into e5
someone's mentioning there's a trick if
the queen takes on f4 it's not
a very tricky trick you just attack two
pieces at once
and then they can't really be saved so
white shouldn't recapture
instead the move g5 is common and we'll
get into what happens in this variation
in our main game here between karjakin
and mvl
but i wanted to highlight what happens
if white decides to focus on this g5
idea instead
and plays this move h4 and so of course
now by giving attention to the g5 idea
and sort of ignoring the threat to the e
pawn
black now switches ideas no longer goes
for g5 and instead focuses
on the e pawn and this is sort of the
way that black is always getting a good
position
from uh this line in the opening he has
these two pretty major threats
that white should try to stop and white
can really only stop one of them
so after h4 of course i like the move
knight c5 very directly very seriously
challenging this e pawn
white can go bishop d3 we'll see knight
takes d3 in many cases
rook takes d3 and d5 and now
e5 and knight e4 and this is the point
of black's play he gangs up on the e4
square with all of his pieces
pushes d5 to liberate his pieces and
plants this knight on e4 and now there
is a game here
also by maxine vashir legrov against
vichyanant in that game continued bishop
e1
queenside castles uh white tried g5
which looks a little blunt
but sort of needed to be done we
actually don't see rick takes h1 sorry
queen b6
and hce2 and i'm blowing through these
moves pretty quickly
but black's play is is sort of solid
here
for example queen g2 and then g6 is the
move i'm going to stop
i'm going to stop on here g6 of course
clamps down white's ideas
on the king's side and black just has a
very very safe
very solid position and there are a ton
of different ideas
that black can go for here of course a5
and b4
is definitely on the cards this knight
on e4 is super solid it's never really
going to be removed from the square
notably if it gets challenged by another
knight
black is generally happy to recapture on
e4 with the pawn
opening up the d file for the rook and
this bishop a bit more
and black's position is just going to be
perfectly fine here
as it was in vishy not against mvl
so like i said sort of these two ideas
from the opening here
one is to challenge e4 and two is to go
for g5
so in the main game we're looking at
between karjakin and maxine vashirogrov
we have bishop g2
so focusing on the e4 idea so instead we
push g5
to challenge f4 white does have another
option here of pushing
f5 instead of pushing for h4 and here i
think e5
is perfectly fine for black for example
now if knight back to b3
we can play it plant this rook onto c8
creating some threats of knight takes e4
for example
immediately that is a threat just to
show
can't recapture with the knight because
of checkmate can't recapture with the
queen because it's defended
so queen e2 should be played and then
from here h5 is a very important move
that totally locks down white's queen
side play now white is not going to be
able to push
h4 because there's so much pressure to
the g4 pawn
so this is sort of our our first real
branch right we have this decision
to stop g5 or stop knight c5 and then we
have this decision to play
f5 or h4 but in either line we see
black's play is actually going to be
pretty similar
the difference here of course is that
the black king is going to stay in the
center
but from here of course black's play is
going to be pretty similar to the other
lines
pushing a5 pushing b4 and attacking on
the queen side
when in the meantime it's really not
clear how you're going to be able to
open things up
on the king's side for white with these
pawns sort of locked together
okay but the main move here is h4 uh
prompting
uh g takes f4 and then g5 by sergey
karjakin so
in this line of course white is sort of
successfully crashing through on the
king's side
uh as compared to the other line that we
saw with f5 which is why this one i
think is a bit more popular
after g5 it's good for black to insert
this inner meso with knight to e5
now of course the the threat of pawn to
e5 has been eliminated
so white can capture on f4
uh and now black sort of has various
options here black can just play knight
after d7 directly
black can actually play the move knight
h5 although it looks a little bit funny
out there but
in the game i think mvl chose the
simplest he simply takes on g5
takes on g5 and eliminates one of the
rooks with rick takes h1
or takes h1 and then drops this other
knight back to d7
and i would say you can kind of
comfortably uh say
that the opening is sort of over and
done with after the next two moves
king b1 was played and queen side
castles and now we
are firmly in a middle game position
here with
mvl uh sort of surviving the opening
without any trace of difficulty
uh now of course if this check were to
be given
rook h8 this might look tempting at
first but black is actually pretty happy
to play the move knight f8
and all of a sudden you've just kind of
walked into uh some unnecessary threats
they're working back to h6 but now black
is very much in time to counter-attack
on the queen side
with moves like b4 moves like queen c4
to come
and yeah just counter-attacking over
here meanwhile
knight gf6 definitely on the cards for
black as well
rerouting the pieces into the game of
course there are
other options here for white besides
just the check and king b1
but black's play is going to be pretty
similar i think against all of them
eventually looking to queen side castle
looking to play b4
and in this game we'll see looking to
improve the pieces in some ways that you
might not expect that's why i want to
show this whole game here
because mvl really introduces some
stellar middle game ideas that are going
to help you
gain a slightly deeper understanding of
the night or
in the game of course we did have king
b1 and queenside castles
uh now uh carjacking chooses the move
rook to h3 adding perhaps a little bit
of extra defense to
some of these weak squares on the third
rank
also uh yeah i guess that's the main
idea
also in some worlds you might need to
double up with something like queen h2
but we're always away from that for now
uh in the game uh mvl
is very very patient he he takes his
time here he realizes
that while everything does look slightly
loose in this position
he actually doesn't have anything to
worry about and so he just plays the
move king
king to b8 uh and now i do want to
mention here uh
sorry i skipped over at first but there
is one very very testing move
for white that karjakin was likely
thinking about
in the game and i i actually remembered
this game from 2017 believe it or not i
watched this tournament live
and to my recollection this move was a
bit of a hot topic
while the game was going on so what move
do you think
kayaking was considering here that would
have been very testing for mvl
to uh to face what move for
white could have been tried here what do
you think
yeah of course another idea with h3 is
to hop over to g3
and perhaps that hints at what the idea
was here
and yeah somebody in the chat does have
it g6
would have been a very testing move and
here black is actually totally busted if
not
for the move rook to g8 this is sort of
the only way for black to play now
and the reason for that is you can't
really get away with taking this pawn
in either manner because of the weakness
to e6
if you take with this guy of course
knight takes e6 is just devastating
but the move rook g8 is going to be good
enough for black to save this game
uh now for example g takes f7 is met
with dirk takes g2
rook h8 check would mean uh sorry not
the king anywhere because it's illegal
but knight f8
and now after knight takes e6 queen c4
and knight takes f8 for example
regaining
the peace but there is queen f1 check
and after king a2 you might actually
lose the game
from rook takes f2 but knight d1
is good enough for white takes on d1
king a2
takes on c2 queen f5 check king b8
night piece knight g6 check king c7
f8 queen and everybody loves a good
old-fashioned perpetual check
everybody loves perpetual check right
don't go there by the way because then
you get met with bishop takes and that
could be bad for you
but perpetual check is going to be good
enough in this case
now does that mean you have to memorize
this line no you can sort of intuitively
find these moves
the only hard move i think to find is
queen c4
after that it's just checking the king
and making sure
you know he can't escape which is not
too bad but yeah g6 would have been a
really interesting try
for white here but i will say i do think
this is sort of no longer a theoretical
position we're definitely running out of
theory here
if like wish to avoid this line
altogether you could consider playing
knight f8 in the
position before castles just to stop g6
altogether
before you castle but g6 is just quite
simply a
a forced draw and i don't know if it's
fair to say that white is on the better
side of the draw he does get two queens
but he does have to be very very careful
about his his king position so
g6 definitely an interesting line in
this case instead we saw the move rook
h3
and king b8 now uh
white sort of has a more difficult time
regrouping these pieces
than black does in the game sergey chose
the move
bishop to e3 and of course
this is aimed at adding a little bit of
defense to
the g5 pawn also perhaps hinting that
the bishop could come to f4
at a later stage and mvl simply plays
the move
rook g8 no no reason to let this g6 idea
stand for longer than it needs to
i should mention if g6 here now the move
knight takes g6
is going to be playable uh
although maybe actually yeah is knight
g6 the right idea i kind of forgot about
this line
uh okay so yeah knight g6 queen f7 you
can bring this knight to e5
now after queen e6 this is no longer
check
so the line is a bit better and mvl
still has some tactical ideas here
of course we did not have to allow this
again could have played rook g8 on this
move maybe that would have been much
much simpler
instead of king b8 but mvl had it all
figured out with king b8 followed by
rook g8
now rook g3 comes on the board trying to
force this idea through
but after rook g7 the idea of g6 sort of
dies
the reason being now whenever you play
this knight takes g6
and my f pawn is defended
so rook g7 and this is the first sort of
interesting repositioning of the pieces
that i found in mvl's game he brings the
rook over to the g file brings it up to
g7
and after that white's only active idea
is sort of shut down
now that mvl has shut down white's only
active idea of playing g6
he can pretty freely go about improving
his pieces here
so the move bishop h3 came on the board
and here
uh mvl actually brings the rook over to
h7
it does the same job of defending f7 and
stopping g6
but it's a little bit more active over
here now we have
queen f2 by white we could have seen
this move coming
it frees up the f4 square for the bishop
and allows
the queen some mobility uh and now the
move
knight c5 is pretty intuitive to bring
the knight to the active c5 square and
pressure
uh e4 some people in the chat were
mentioning some ideas of knight a4 to
challenge the knight on c3
and that is definitely true although i
don't think it makes as much sense here
as we don't have that sort of lethal
pressure down the c file that's when
knight f4 is a good idea when you have
this pressure
on the c file and you really just want
to evict this knight
in this case though we're happy on c5
challenging e4
the bishop drops back to g2 to parry
this threat
and now i sort of want to ask you what
to do
with this bishop what interesting idea
does maxime have here to improve
the positioning of this bishop what can
you do to make your pieces even better
uh someone is saying it belongs on g7
so f8 to g7 is definitely an idea
so what um maxine does is actually a
pretty typical idea in the night or
it turns out maybe this bishop would be
decent
on the g7 square i don't know
i don't know if it's my favorite
actually and i think there are some
problems with going bishop f8
in particular this problem but if we
could in some magic world
get it to g7 i think it would be pretty
good i don't know if it's actually going
to be realistic though maybe you can try
knight g6 first
something like knight d2 bishop f8
and and get here this way but
it does take some time and it is
allowing white
some pressure on uh of of playing the
move g6
uh but yeah that's not a bad idea at all
it's actually really interesting idea
that you guys are mentioning here and
maybe it's
maybe it's worth a try in some games but
the idea that maxine uses
is actually a bit more common in the
najdorf it's going
queen c8 now how does queen see it
improve this bishop
well of course our idea is to not go
bishop f8 but rather go bishop
d8 and activate the bishop along
the d8 to a5 diagonal and
yeah this shows up all the time in
other lines in the nightdorf but mvl
shows that it can be a very very good
idea here as well
so queens eight was his move uh sergey
drops this bishop back to c1
and now we do actually see bishop d8
knight f3
knight g6 sort of stepping out of the
trait of knights
this knight comes back to d4 we see one
repetition
and then after knight back to d4 mvl
does play the move bishop b6
deciding to continue the game rather
than accept a repetition
and for very good reason here he has
found ways to improve his pieces
in the meantime white's pieces are are
sort of as improved as they can get
two pieces passively defending e4 this
bishop
passively defending g5 and the kings
or in the queen side i guess and this
knight with some active play
but not really achieving a whole lot
against
black's solid setup here and
because of that black has a ton of
freedom in this position to sort of play
however he wants which is exactly what
mvl does
sergey brings the bishop back to e3 and
mvl brings the knight back
to e5 now if uh
sergey were to try the same repetition
we would definitely step into c4
rather than back to g6 putting pressure
on the bishop so he goes b3 instead
to try and contest the square although
this does
create some long-term weaknesses on the
queen side for
white and now after rook h4
the pressure on the e pawn is definitely
mounting we have knight
d to e2 queen up to c7
bishop d4 knight cd7 once again playing
very slowly white's threatening to
fracture our pawns so knight cd7 is fine
he doesn't mind
trading off some pieces and in the long
run
these two pawns are going to be very
very weak for white and that's sort of
the story of the game
mvl does end up winning thanks to the
weakness made by having these two pawns
knight d4 played in the game knight g6
and i'm going to speed up a bit now
because we're sort of well past the
middle game
king d2 this knight comes to f4 king e3
takes check takes check king d2
knight e5 knight d e2
check king c1 knight h4
and some maneuvering the king comes into
the game
towards the f pawn 95 again
we see some passing some fumbling around
and a trait of the knights and the g
pawn falls this is sort of the first one
to go
and then after d5 uh sergey karyakin
actually just resigns
in this position rather than play out
this end game uh with the g
pawn gone black is going to get two
connected past pawns
uncontested and that is going to be the
story of the game and that's how this
game ended sergei residing
perhaps a bit early but in a technically
lost endgame
and the story of this game very much was
once mvl was able to stop this idea of
g6
sergey was left with very little uh in
the way of active ideas
of ways to improve his pieces and
meanwhile the play for black was very
very natural you bring the bishop to a
better diagonal
you bring the knights to good squares
and then
the position sort of plays itself with
some pressure on the queen side as well
so any questions on this game this is
like i said
probably the most common line against
the uh
nightdorf in the bishop g5 variation
this move knight a3 to keep the b
pawn and sort of go for this kingside
attack i think it's very very common
these days so any questions on this
before we move on
to some other stuff okay what if
g6 instead of bishop h3 it looks
good
all right well let's take a look backing
all the way up
to bishop h3
g6 here uh we can just take
and we are defending f7 right i i did
mention this briefly
if you want to take this guy rick takes
g6
there is actually an annoying knight e5
here
this check doesn't do anything just
queen d8 and yeah
i don't know blacks blacks up a lot of
pieces
i guess not a lot of pieces but black's
pieces are very active and
winning an f-pawn wasn't really worth it
for you
all right well with that let us move on
to the next variation so now i'm going
to hop
into a line where white actually allows
you to capture
that b2 pawn this is some very fighting
stuff and this is where
the theory does get a bit heavier than
in the line with a3 i know we went
really deep with the theory on move 15
16 17 but it was very linear whereas
here
white does have a few different pretty
serious options to look at
so to start off with i want to show you
guys a game between francisco vallejo
ponce
and alexander marozovic and this game
goes of course
the opening moves of the night or don't
need to spend too much time
uh a6 bishop g5 e6 f4
is what we're looking at uh h6 for the
delayed poison pawn
bishop h4 queen b6 queen d2
and this is the move that allows you to
capture on
b2 so let's take a look queen takes b2
uh and now there is sort of a sideline
that i want to mention here of course
the main move by far
is the very very natural rook b1
if white tries to move knight p3 then we
can actually again
make use of the fact that this bishop is
on an undefended square with the move
bishop e7
now if rook b1 this is sort of a
horrible blunder because knight takes e4
challenges the queen and the knight and
the bishop
so you can't go rook uh rook b1
and here bishop f6 is actually the best
that white can do to not end up any
worse
if you go a4 trying to trap the queen in
a different manner then once again
knight takes e4 is just too good for
black
so bishop f6 bishop f6 and from here
you can play the move knight a4 hitting
the queen stepping out of the threat of
the bishop
queen a3 should be played and now the
only line to not be significantly worse
for white well i guess not to be losing
for white is to play knight b6
bishop takes uh knight takes a1
queen c5 net a8 and here what black can
simply play the move b6 and
recapture this knight fairly easily
with either queen c6 or bishop b7 to
follow for example knight p3 queen c6
knight p6 queen b6 and black is doing
just fine here
so just a little sideline i wanted to
mention in
general thanks to the misplacement of
this bishop bishop e7
is usually a really good response to
most of black's
most of white's threats against this
black queen early on on the queen's side
just to remind just to remember rook b1
though is
the actual move now queen a3 should
should be played
and here i'm going to look at three
different options for white three
different branches
number one is the move f5 which i'm
going to take a look at first
number two is the move e5 which is
actually the more common
and number three i'm going to see what
happens if white actually decides to
take this knight on
f6 so number one the move f5 looks
pretty challenging
right similar to the sozen attack
white is going to be ready to bring the
bishop out to c4
and challenge the light squares in the
black
camp but no need to fear for black
thanks to this bishop once again we can
play the move bishop e7
and we are actually now developing with
tempo with ideas of taking on e4
white must take on e6 to not be worse f
takes e6
bishop c4 we don't take with the bishop
in this case
because we need the bishop back on c8 to
defend the e6 pawn from these attacks
now bla white has actually allowed our
big tactic
this is why we put the bishop on h4 so
that we have this knight takes e4 tactic
and when white allows it we should
generally generally play it
knight takes c4 bishop takes h4 comes
with check
and after g3 we get into what is sort of
the most
theory-heavy stuff here uh already where
15 moves deep but theory does
actually keep going so just quick
refresher on how we got here
queen a3 after rook b1 is very very
standard f5
is sort of the decision point for white
we develop our piece with a threat to e4
takes on e6 takes bishop c4 and now
takes on e4 that's where we're at
so knight takes e4 is forced bishop
takes g3 is forced
and now bishop g5 is the idea
for black the point being we really do
need to start eliminating some of these
attacking pieces around our king
or else we could get into serious
trouble notably if knight takes d6 here
okay sorry i forgot the queen just
defends it
um so white
is more or less forced to capture on g5
or again he's going to be significantly
worse after something like d5
so knight takes g5 is forced we have h
takes g5 now
and the deep point for black is that
we have a tactic everybody loves a good
old-fashioned tactic
so knight takes e6 is the way to
continue for white otherwise
uh sorry yeah so knight takes e6
it would normally be the way to continue
for white
these days castles is actually a bit
more common because of the tactic i just
highlighted so 96
bishop e6 bishop e6 and now let's see if
you guys can find
the full sequence here what is the full
tactic i've gave you a very strong hint
with my arrows but what is the full line
here
for black to equalize
what's the idea for black nobody has it
nobody has it
uh so yeah queen takes g3 and the idea
is not to win
all of the rooks but to win back one
of the rooks with h takes g3 rook takes
h1
king e2 and now rook takes b1 would be
asking to get checkmated
but we do actually have rook h2 check
here with the point being
we get to take the queen back as well
and the fact of the matter is
this is just a slightly better end game
for black
uh everything is pretty much symmetrical
but he ends up with an extra g pawn
which of course
not the most useful thing in the world
but not bad to have either
uh black should try to defend this pawn
momentarily with move rook a7
after bishop d5 though it does make
sense just to develop
and give this pawn back if you try
something like d5 you're going to get
met with a4
and this is going to be tough for you to
keep this pawn
anyways so knight d7 for example
uh and sorry yeah knight d7
rook b7 rook b7 bishop b7 knight c5
bishop e3 king d7
and the game was agreed to a draw here
between vallejo ponce and
mirozovic so backing up a little bit
we very quickly got from opening theory
to the end of the game which does happen
sometimes
but in this position i was saying knight
e6 does seem like the logical move
but thanks to this very clever tactic
with queen g3 and rook h1
black is doing just fine here so these
days castles
is going to be a bit more common i think
and here uh the only move for black is
to play the move queen c5 you need to
pin this knight to the king
make sure it's not going to come kill
you and
now with threats to the knight and the
bishop uh
white should play the move uh queen to
f2
and the point now for black
is not to actually capture this piece
when of course you would like die
you don't want to die here dying is bad
but instead you get to play the move
knight c6 and the point is you want to
capture this piece
with check you are threatening this guy
and
from here the only move for white to not
kind of lose the game
is going to be the move not queen f7
which would
lose a piece no way to save the piece
here
takes takes takes with check rook f2
and yeah actually probably you you don't
take this guy
now you can just take this guy queen
takes
maybe you don't want to take that guy
maybe you just play b5 here
and develop your pieces and now
i guess black is not up a piece but he
is up three pawns
and not immediately checkmated he is
just going to be winning this position
so two really critical ideas for black
queen c5
queen f2 knight c6 have to know those
two
in this line from here like i said the
only line for white is actually to take
on e6
now we have takes takes takes takes
and here we get a similar looking end
game with one extra set of rooks on the
board
the difference here of course is with
the extra rook
the black king being a little bit way
laid matters a bit more
but black gets to keep this pawn for
just a few moments longer
so bishop d5 is the main move knight e5
bishop takes b7 king e7
and here there's actually a game uh a
few games
and uh maxine with srila grav has had
this position
two times and he has drawn it quite
easily both times from this position
it's a pretty easy end game with this
knight being so strongly placed
on the central square of e5 indirectly
sort of pressuring the king side keeping
the c pawn at bay
and black should have absolutely no
difficulties in this end game
at all and those are
pretty much the two most theory-heavy
variations
in the night or so let's go over it one
more time we had queen d2
allowing you to take the poison pawn
queen b1
sorry rook b1 queen a3 f5 challenging
the e6 pawn
bishop e7 takes takes bishop c4
he allowed our tactics so we played it
check
bishop back to g5 knight takes g5 is
forced
hg5 and now 96 allows our big tactic
here
if queen takes g3 and
kingside castles means queen c5 pinning
the knight
queen f2 means knight c6 uh attacking
the knight again
which i know seems like a lot but
you know what's the night or what are
you gonna do sometimes you gotta know
stuff right and that's that's why the
bishop g5 variations do have this
reputation
for being very theory heavy that being
said while it is kind of a lot it took
15 minutes to go through all of this
part and so hopefully
it's not too much for you guys to to
remember if you do
end up deciding to play the night of
yourselves
with that in mind let's move on to
another game and another idea we went
over the idea of f5 and let's take a
look now at the main move
of e5 and to do so we are going back
again
once again to maxima shirlegraf with the
black pieces he
like i said really championed this
variation and is the main proponent of
it at the top level
uh this was a game he had against anish
giri
that went with all of these same night
of opening moves e4 c5
a6 bishop g5 e6 f4
and queen b6 so in this case
mvl did not actually do the delayed
poison pawn
just played queen b6 immediately but
we'll see he does transpose quite
quickly
queen d2 is played takes rook b1 queen
a3
and after e5 h6 bishop h4
we are at our main position here so you
can easily imagine
for example this position could have
gotten here by
this move order instead right queen a3
e5
and like i said this is one of the main
ideas for white in this position playing
e5 here
um so let me
duck back over to the actual game
and so here we are so how should you
respond to this
with uh black well of course it makes
sense
to actually capture this pawn on e5 with
the d-pawn
the reason for that is it gives your
queen and your bishop access to this
long diagonal
and for two it actually does weaken this
e5 pawn pretty considerably so de5
fe 5 should be played always and
now there are a few different
ideas here for black you can try the
move g5 which is actually the most
common but i actually liked this line
the least when i was
preparing for this lecture it just seems
needlessly complicated and
not very good for black if if anything
goes wrong
whereas i think the other two moves are
going to be a bit of a better try
for black so
uh in alex kolovich's
chessable series i have been using that
sort of as a reference for some of these
lines seeing what he suggests
he actually suggests the move knight d5
here and
this line felt a little bit fishy um
i i'm sure it's actually fine for black
if you play very very well
but believe it or not i did actually try
playing some games in the night or
before giving all these lectures and i
whenever i played knight d5 i just was
not i was not so happy with my position
so looking at it i do think i really
like the third option here the best for
black which is to play the move knight
fd7
and this is asking for some pretty
serious complications
uh the reason for that is you are very
directly attacking
this e5 pawn and it is very much in
white's best interest to allow you to
take it
if he tries to defend it for example
he's asking for the move bishop b4
when things are getting very very
awkward for whites along this diagonal
no clear way for how to break free
and in the meantime this is still going
to be a big weakness so
94 should definitely be played for white
this is sort of the only move
defending b4 with two pieces and
now being very very greedy we are going
to take even more pawns with queen takes
a2
just give me all of the pawns now rook
d1
should be played for white to step out
of the attack
to the rook keeping an eye on the first
rank
and queen d5 makes sense now for
for black forking the knight and the
pawn
queen e3 is an attempt to defend
everything but after queen takes e5
we've taken
one two three extra pawns for
our troubles so of course white is going
to need
something pretty extreme to make up for
a three pawn deficit
and we'll see that he is actually able
to to get enough compensation
for the three pawns uh
the way to achieve this is with the move
bishop e2 just naturally developing
and now it's not the time to dilly dally
with black we need to develop as quickly
as possible so bishop c5
pressuring the center bishop g3
queen d5 is one choice bishop takes d4
is another choice really they both have
the same
idea of eventually playing bishop takes
d4 the only difference is
after queen d5 you provoke this pawn out
to the c4 square
and so queen d5 was mvl's choice in this
game
it really changes the variations so so
so very little and i don't think it's
going to be
too much of a relevant difference so
queen d5 in this game
c4 was played by anish giri we have
bishop takes d4
rook takes d4 queen a5 check
note like i said you can get here from
this position as well
it's almost identical um queen a5 check
rook back to d2 to block the check king
side castles now
for black and then white's idea is
finally made clear with the move bishop
d6
and the point here is that it's very
very difficult for black
to keep this rook on the board
this rook is going to more or less
eventually
have to kill itself off for this dark
squared bishop
one way or another it's just kind of a
question
of how the move that's the most common
is actually rook d8 but i like mvl's
move a bit better but let's take a quick
look at rook d8 just to show you
that black really shouldn't be trying to
keep this guy white is very quickly
going to play g4
trying to checkmate you knight c6 for
example kingside castles
knight d to e5 and after h4
already black should be capturing this
bishop if you don't then g5
is going to come very very quickly and
you're going to run into
some pretty major issues here if you
just try to develop nonchalantly
knight f6 check and you are busted my
friend
very very busted so rook takes d6 would
eventually be played here anyways and
the point now is after something like
knight takes
you go b6 g5
uh g5 and you go queen c5 and try to
trade off the queens
that's why you have to get rid of this
bishop so you have these ideas of
trading off the queens
that being said i don't recommend any of
that i'm just showing you
what uh is sort of the most common and
why black can't actually keep all of
this material to himself
because he very much does want the trade
of queens so instead
mvl's move is f5 which i do like
uh better than the move rook d8
partially because it's more forcing and
so there's less to know
because white is going to have to make
uh
white's decisions are going to be
uh white's going to have less decisions
to to make which can be a bad thing
because your opponent has less chances
to go wrong if they
only you know if they can only play
forced moves but it's also a good thing
because you don't have to remember as
much so after f5
bishop takes f8 should be played now
knight takes f8
is the obvious move knight d6 puts a lot
of pressure
on black's position but he can just
develop with the move knight b to d7
now there are two different options here
for
whites but i do kind of think it's safe
to say
that we are very much out of the opening
once we play this move knight bd7
i am going to like uh just call it once
the queens are off the board
until then black still has some problems
left to solve but
after knight bd7 uh it is sort of just a
middle game position
the only thing that's left to do for
black like i said is to make sure that
these queens
end up getting traded off the board
fortunately
for black it is not very difficult to
ensure that that happens
by force so there are two options like i
said
for uh for white that are pretty serious
there's the move g4 which is generally
met with f takes g4
there's a game that goes bishop takes g4
and then to get the queens off
mvl goes queen i1 check rook d1
queen e5 so like i said very very direct
just
force the queens off the board and then
black is totally totally fine
so that's g4 i don't want to get too
in-depth into it
the point is you take off the you take
off the queens
and then black is doing okay another
choice
for white is actually to move bishop f3
and here once again queen a1 check is
not a bad idea
with queen e5 to follow so i'm kind of
counting those as the same thing
now white's other idea is sort of more
natural just to castle the king
and here of course queen e5 isn't ever
pinning the uh
pinning the queen to the king but queen
c5 is and that's what we see get played
in this game
and so after this move black has sort of
solved all of the opening problems by
ensuring
that the queens get off the board of
course black's pieces are still slightly
awkwardly placed
but i definitely don't think it's it's
an opening task any longer
so if you are really trying to memorize
everything i think you can safely
wash your hands of this variation by
this move
once queens are off the board it's it's
out of the opening and black just needs
to you know play good chess
with all of that in mind let's get a
feel for how this end game
might go we have the move queen d4
a5 g4
so white goes queen d4 to
try and bait black into capturing on d4
uh
sort of improving the rook and then goes
g4 to open up this
the position in the meantime mvl pushes
a5 trying to make his past pawn a little
bit more relevant
not a bad idea at all you know rather
than move the rook to a developed square
why not just develop it by pushing this
pawn forward it's a sort of a neat idea
and then now mvl actually chooses the
strange looking
f4 which is definitely a pawn sacrifice
that is a little bit mysterious to me
but i do think is perfectly fine
perhaps simpler would be to play
something like g6 and just try to keep
everything
safe and solid once again black's king
looks very very weak
but with queens coming off the board
sort of immediately
there's not too much to be afraid of
here for uh for black
especially with these knights covering a
lot of the weak squares
in the black camp along with this bishop
in the game though we do see f4
rook takes f4 and now perhaps the
simplest
for black would have been to play the
move e5
and now after something like bishop b6
all of his pieces would be developed
all of his pieces would be in the game
and i don't think there's any reason
why he should be worse with two full
pawns
for the exchange in the game though he
chose the move a4
pushing the pawn even further rick f1
queen takes d4 check
knight out to c5 and after
a3 we do really feel the presence of
this a
pawn white manages to win back one of
the pawns though
and now we get this end game where white
should actually be
slightly better thanks to the activity
of his pieces he's able to sort of
get that material imbalance down from
two pawns for the exchange to just one
pawn for the exchange
but with that in mind so few pieces left
on the board
the white king is very very exposed
black should have no
major issues in trying to draw this
still although it definitely didn't have
to get to this point
again i think that move e5 definitely
would have been simpler for mvl
in the game though rook a2 was played
rook d8 rook takes a3 picking up the a
pawn now like i said this was
going to happen thanks to the activity
of white's pieces but now rook d2
and mvl has activity of his own h3
knight back to f6 rook f rookie 3 king
f7
rook f2 check king over to e7
rook a3 94 and
more chess moves and after rook takes g7
it all starts going downhill for a niche
geary very very quickly
there's a check a knight d4 move
and after king f2 knight d3 check and
white actually
resigned in this position because this
is attacked
and if king e3 knight f5 forks
the remaining brook and king and so mvl
actually did go on to win this game of
course it was a rapid game so by this
point
the players were not playing their best
the emphasis
was more on that opening and early
middle game
where we saw mvl solving his problems uh
by
getting the queens off the board and
then pushing that a pawn to develop his
rook some very common ideas
in this opening line now i know that
that was
another sort of bear of a ton
of theory but most of the moves are
sort of intuitive right let's go through
them one by one one more time so we have
our starting position
f4 now once again i'm recommending this
move order but it doesn't really matter
in this particular game e5 and
that brings us here d takes e5 fe5
knight d7 trying to pick up the pawn
knight e4
we take on a2 hitting the rook on b1
and then go queen d5 after queen e3 we
take on e5 just take all the stuff
here we need to develop very quickly so
bishop c5
bishop g3 our queen's attacked so queen
d5
or bishop takes d4 first uh so queen d5
baiting c4
so c4 takes takes queen out to a5 with
check
rook d2 then we get castled bishop d6
we don't care about our rook we just
push f5
takes on f8 takes on f8 knight d6 knight
bd7 getting developed
and then from here our last task is to
get the queens off the board
which we should more or less always be
able to force for example
castles queen c5 or g4
takes takes queen e5 all right sorry
rather queen a1 check first is good
and then queen e5 queen e5 immediately
not a bad move either
so i know that's a lot to sort of take
in this is definitely
a lot of theory but like i said we're
covering pretty much all
of the crazy stuff here in this one hour
lecture if it can be taught in one hour
i trust you guys to be able to to learn
all of it
um with that in mind i am going to open
up to questions about this line
uh really quickly and then i am going to
with my remaining four minutes maybe
stretch the class just a teensy bit long
and look at one last variation uh for
you guys
yeah putting in h6 is very importance um
[Music]
but in the move order in this game black
delayed
doing it until when he knew that he was
going to have to uh
sort of take sorry when he knew that
white was going to play e5
here it is very very important to play
the move h6 i believe
although actually maybe you can play d
take c5 but yeah h6 i think is just a
better one
but with our move order we always have
h6 on the board anyways so we don't even
have to worry about that
mvl just chose a different line in this
case that transposed
are we booked up yet are we ready to
play the bishop g5 line so not just yet
not just yet great wolf i think there is
going to be a part two i am going to
analyze
just one more variation before we call
the class quits here
and then i'm going to do a quick review
of what we haven't actually covered yet
uh there's not too much left though i i
promise
so i mentioned the idea of f5 here
sorry um in this position i mentioned
the idea of f5 the idea of e5
but white does have one more pretty
serious try and that is to take on f6
so let's analyze this very quickly
bishop takes f6 and to do so we're going
to take notes
from a game between dimitri kokorev and
peter lecko
so very quickly let's do this takes an
f6 g takes f6
now bishop e2 is an attempt to sometimes
plant this bishop
on h5 and take advantage of some weak
dark square
we light squares for black so h5 is a
good multi-purpose move
for black to stop the bishop from
getting here also slow down the king's
side pawns
white castles and now it's good to bring
the queen back into the game
back to a5 here uh the move king h1
actually makes a lot of sense because at
a later date black is going to play
queen c5
and white wants the queen on this
diagonal but might not necessarily want
to trade the queens
so knight c6 instead knight takes c6 b
takes c6 getting developed
queen d4 bishop e7
and now after knight a4 the ideas
here for black are basically just to
play this move d5
and he's going to solve his problem of
the king
by playing king f8 and king g7 at a
later date that we'll see so i played
through these moves
rather quickly but the benefit here for
black
is that you get this nice big strong
center that well while it is very
compact it is very
uh solid very tough to crack and so i
think black should
be perfectly safe in this line as well
as we see in this game
queen d4 was played bishop b7 knight a4
and yeah d5 is a good break in general
for black here
knight b6 attacks two pieces at the same
time rook b8 saves the rook
we get a trade rook b7 at first glance
looks very threatening
but now queen c5 evicts this queen bla
white would not be so happy with this
queen trade
when black's uh pawns are actually doing
quite well for him
in fact i think black is still
technically up upon
at the moment so after queen c5 this was
the point of king h1 now the queen can
move back to d3
keeping some attacking ideas alive but
king f8 is a good move now for black
and black is ready to step to g7
whenever necessary to get out of danger
the game continued with f5 black of
course wants to keep this
file closed so e5 is a natural response
and now the players began a great
shuffling
technique where they all moved back and
forth
until they agreed that the game should
be declared a draw
which happened here in some team
championship i think between
kokarev and peter lecko
so instead of a through or queen e2 what
if white does bishop takes f6
so that's what we're looking at right
now yashas his bishop takes f6
um so those are i think the three real
main options
for white after this move uh queen d2
that we see here
right so there were two really main
ideas a3 and queen d2
queen d2 allows you to take on b2 and
that's what we looked at here in these
past three games
and a3 is what we looked at in the first
game between carjacking and mvl
i think they're both very very common uh
in my database a3 is played a little bit
more often
at the higher levels but definitely both
worth knowing
a3 like i said very linear theory so you
can go pretty deep into the position
and get by with an understanding of
ideas from
there queen d2 there are those three
main ideas of f5
e5 and bishop takes f6 all of which we
looked at
very briefly and then lastly
the stuff that we didn't cover so here
there is one or two more ideas for white
you can play the move queen to d3 here
or you can play the move bishop
takes f6 we're going to take a look at
both of those next week
they're not very serious tries for white
though white does actually just get
worse versions
of everything we've looked at here today
with these variations in my opinion
uh of course there are actually some
moves for white besides
f4 when we think of the bishop g5 night
or we think of this move f4 that's sort
of the
main variation but we are going to look
at some of these other developing moves
that white can choose here as well
in the next lecture and that's sort of
all that's remaining in bishop g5
and in fact that's almost all that's
remaining in the entire naidorf series
i'm probably going to do
one or two wrap-up lectures where i
cover sort of the odds and ends
the bits and pieces that i missed along
the way
uh and as well as some sidelines that
that come out pretty early on
but you guys if you've been following
the series thus far
should be pretty close to having a
complete understanding of the nidorf we
are definitely in the home stretch thank
you guys so much for sticking it out
with me on this series i've had a lot of
fun
putting all this stuff together and i
can't wait to
get to the the epic conclusions of it
all right that's it from us here tonight
on youtube the fun will continue
live on twitch if you guys are still
with us if you're watching
the recorded version once again my name
is caleb denby thank you so much for
watching and i will see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you